when you're starting something it's just
hard you need to be pretty headstrong
about it or and they're gonna be all
these challenges that come up and I
think the main thing that you need to do
is just not give up I don't know what
you want to do and the best
entrepreneurs that who I've met don't
really start companies because their
goal is to build a company they do it
because they want to make a change in
the world and help people and I think if
you stay true to that and and if you
just focus on kind of powering through
no matter what the the challenges are
that will inevitably come up in your
path then you'll find that there are
lots of tools that are available and a
lot of people who will help you build
what you're building one definition that
I have for a good team is a group of
people that makes better decisions as a
whole than would individually make is a
sum of the parts I think most smart
people like learning I mean that's like
one of the thrills of starting a company
the learning curve can be so steep and
if you can set up a team dynamic where
you're constantly learning from the
people around you then I mean what's
better these are the people I wake up
every morning I want to go learn from
and whispering and when building a team
you want it to you want to think about
the dynamics so that way you can
maintain this property that the team
makes better decisions as a group than
any individual would you just watch -
amazing clips of Mark Zuckerberg take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you